da ein kamera youtube trends ganz
schlimm katja bringt jetzt auch noch
einen kalender raus so versaut ist
meinen kritiker nein es schneit es
schneit draußen tust leute katja hat
bringt jetzt auch noch ein kalender aus
oder hat sie schon
ich weiß es nicht ich muss mir das mal
kurz angucken also ich muss ganz ehrlich
sagen den song fand ich ja gar nicht so
schlecht ich weiß nicht ob ihr das
gesehen habe den fand ich nicht schlecht
und manche sachen verstehe ich bei der
echt nicht meins ein mikrofon das kostet
80 euro eine gute kamera kostet jetzt
sag mal 800 euro ja und wenn man dann
allein schon durch den song sicherlich
mehrere zehntausend verdient dann geh
doch einfach zum saturn und kaufte eine
kamera muss ich mir jetzt auch hier
nicht so ein toaster angucken
das trifft sich sehr gut eigentlich weil
ich brauch noch nikolaus geschenk für
meine mitbewohner und für meine eltern
meine fragen mit was nimmt sie das jetzt
gerade auf das ist ja nicht mal ein von
qualität das ist ja ein iphone 5 besser
als das der ton ist wirklich eine
katastrophe
die muss ich haben drei bitte bei
1.000.000 1
lass mich raten david du bist 12 ich bin
wirklich
also ich muss sagen an sich hatte ich
jetzt nie wirklich was gegen die aber
ich habe ja sogar gesagt den song fand
ich gar nicht so schlecht aber irgendwie
mit diesen ganzen alles was sie sagt zum
beispiel man merkt falls du selber wenn
man youtuber ist wenn man wenn man sich
auch ein bisschen mit marketing auskennt
das ist eigentlich eine komplette rotz
ist und dass er nicht stimmt
wahrscheinlich sagt jetzt gleich dass
sie auch auf jeden fall bei instagram
folgen soll
weil ihr vielleicht ja auch dann den
kalender bekommt von ihren umsonst kennt
ihr euch dann über euer bett hängen
mami ist bestimmt begeistert klar sind
wir voll geil ich will mir das
eigentlich gar nicht weiter anschauen an
dieser stelle aber noch von dem jungen
von dem sie gerade erzählt hat er
wahrscheinlich nicht mal existiert
herzlichen glückwunsch einig viel spaß
mit dem kalender
er geht nicht das ist ja mal ganz
ehrlich die jugend verblödet ich stelle
mir vor rund drei wochen läuft jedes
mädchen mit so pietsch sie kann rum und
klebt ihren freundinnen auf nach oder
was okay jetzt mal spaß beiseite ich
habe ja eben schon gesagt ich brauche
wirklich noch nikolaus geschenk für
meine mitbewohner etwas zu
nikolausgeschenk ich mich leider nicht
finde ich würd sagen ich habe auf jeden
fall das richtige gefunden so wir gucken
jetzt mal auf dem ich heiße das muss ich
ja sofort zensieren also sorry dass ich
das gerade alles zensieren muss aber es
ist besser so wo ist der kalender
nein nein
scheiße jetzt ist er schlecht kalender
aus wieso ist der kalender aus mag ich
frage mich ehrlich ist es jetzt eine
verarsche ihr könnt mir doch nicht
sorgen
mal angenommen es gab 1000 kalender was
ich jetzt eigentlich noch für relativ
wenig einstufe du kannst du doch jetzt
nicht erzählen dass diese 1000 kalender
schon weg sind ich meine man kann doch
als 13-jähriger junge schlecht zu seiner
mama gehen und sagen mami ich wünsche
mir zu weihnachten den katja gasser
wirklich kalender erotik indischen für
2018 also ernsthaft also da bin ich
jetzt wenig erstaunt natürlich kann es
auch sein das ist sehr sehr viele ältere
menschen gibt die sich so was bestellen
nicht komplett krank ehrlich muss ich
mal so sagen kummer und wegen euch krieg
ich jetzt kein ich wollte mein
mitbewohner so ein schönes geschenk
machen ich denke jetzt zwar nicht dass
es auch wirklich annehmen würde
aber man kann es ja mal versuchen ich
habe eigentlich noch eine witzige idee
wir machen jetzt unseren eigenen
kalender das ist zwar ein bisschen
aufwand aber ich habe heute noch zeit
und ja ich will ja nicht dann gelaufen
seid gespannt
ich bin mal kurz weg sechseinhalb
stunden später
also servicegrad eine schere gekauft ich
habe vater fixiert
das war endlich das leichteste und ich
habe an seiner tankstelle um die ecke
einen erotik kalender gekauft ich wusste
gar nicht dass sowas hab 18 ist ich
musste mein ausweis zeigen egal war auf
jeden fall ein sehr komisches gefühl
so und jetzt machen wir unseren eigenen
kalender also jetzt und ich hatte noch
bei photoshop dieses gesicht
herausgeschnitten
insgesamt ein stück und dieses
offizielle logo hab ich auch noch
gefunden und jetzt machen wir mal schön
entspannt was das schöne mit alex hast
du das hier ist übrigens der kalender
ich weiß jetzt nicht was man da
zensieren muss
juli
so leute ich bin fertig es ist wirklich
so mega gut geworden ich zeige euch das
auf jeden fall jetzt gleich man muss
natürlich auch eine menge zensieren aber
juli also mein mitbewohner ist gerade
gekommen und wir gehen jetzt mal ist
tolle geschenke überreichen doch mal
sehen ob das alle mit und sich frei ich
bin auf jeden fall positiv gestimmt hey
willst du wegen grüßen also was ist
gemacht
als oder jugend wieder so was tolles
geschenkt und ich hatte ja kein geschenk
für dich
und da habe ich mich jetzt aber noch im
nach dem gesetz habe mir ein paar
gedanken gemacht kann nix kurve wallis
in front
was brauchen jetzt habe ich das perfekte
geschenk was du dir eigentlich genau so
wie sie heute nicht mehr wahrscheinlich
eh nicht gewünscht und ich ist absolute
kacke nein passiert irgendwas aber nein
kommt man mit ach so man kann auch mal
kurz auf das gewinnspiel aufmerksam
machen leute
das gibt es alles zu gewinnen hier wir
haben hier ja eine playstation iphone
lockenstab links vom scam morgen im
video gibt es auf jeden fall wieder was
zu gewinnen also wir sehen uns morgen
und hier habe ich habe mir gedacht weil
wir jetzt ein großer katja fan bist ich
weiß ja bis mitbekommen was hat sie denn
gerade rausgebracht besitzt das ich
singe gibt es bilder wie nein was sie
hat jetzt so etwas anderes heraus
gebracht und ich habe mir gedacht da
greift er doch mal zu leider war das
ganze sofort ausverkauft
ich habe keinen mehr bekommen auf jeden
fall habe ich jetzt nicht mal selber
hingesetzt hat was gebastelt also das
schlechte männer ein gleich zum grillen
das ist nicht einfach nur bestellt und
dann kannst du dir jetzt eigentlich ins
zimmer hin
du hast das extra ausgedruckt wie viel
mühe die gegeben als beim ausschneiden
ich habe sogar extra erotik an den kopf
und ist der verkäufer hat mich so dumm
kommt dich war auf die idee das ist ja
verschiedene größen wie herr klar ich
habe verschiedene größen gewählt da
warte ich habe es nicht auf die idee den
spielen zudem kannst du das überhaupt
sein nein ich wusste dass wenn sie ihre
das midler daniel h
bei 50.000 aufbruch gibt es das video
anzusehen
auch weiter anderen plattform kostet ab
ist doch super pflanzen neben der
eingangstür sind wir direkt im januar
auf steuersoftware kitzeln verdammt
schön wenn hier die verlangten kommt
halt ja heute das erste video schauen
was hat euch gefallen als nach oben
drauf als ist der fall ist und ja leider
habe ich den originalen kanada nicht
bekommen ich bin auch traurig wie kriege
ich noch echt wir lassen auf ebay gucken
also wir sehen uns morgen wieder und
daumen hoch
daher stellt einen markt südlich länge
der beschreibung schreibt vorbei